had a great event today with Kam Chay
and the guys here in Birmingham I just
want to say that before you watch this
video you're going to have a good time
watching it trust me before you watch
this video click the link below and
donate to Prov Palestine these guys 313
have been fully vetted they're on the
ground 100% they're doing great work we
need you to donate it's going to be
amazing wor the
videos everybody and
special to you ham how are you
alhamdulillah very good brother nice to
be here brother I see all my brothers on
the so good well I think everyone will
agree that it's nice to see you too
would you
agree
alhamdulillah I wanted to ask you some
questions um a lot of things as you know
are happening in Palestine and other
places and we really appreciate the fact
that you're here in this charity event
okay it's good to see a fighter coming
outside of his comfort zone and doing
things like this and I wanted to ask you
how does it make you feel first of all
what seeing what you're seeing in
Palestine
it's you can't say these things with the
world's Master you feel in their heart
our heart is it so everyone knows what's
happening in Palestine now so it's I'm
almost the same country like this we
went through the same thing so we had
the war in the country as well somebody
knows about that so we know about that
so know and it's hard hard kids dying
you know so we seen today like in the
movies the kids ding but now it's in
real life the kids dying you know so
it's hard Shah we hope soon it's over
and we make du every day
and I don't know what to say brother it
feels
it's no words for that
brother you were asked one time um by
one of the reporters about how you feel
and you came across as quite emotional
and a lot of people grew in respect for
you because they saw a side of you that
it cared about other people it cared
about your Muslim brothers and sisters
you care about other human beings
children who are being hurt mothers
children what message would you send to
decision makers policy makers
in terms of a ceasefire in terms of
stopping what's happening and in terms
of
Palestine so first I want to say stay
strong to these guys and to these people
Shah everything is not like forever
everything going to go over you know
so whereever war and hard times in your
life everything is going to get over
like we all human MIM like going to live
100 years it's over you know so we have
to fix our life is dead when we die Mar
and
inah the kids who is dying they we know
they they they straight way they going
to Paradise so some way makes happy when
you feel when you when you know they go
paradise and some it's hard to see them
how they die you know how they go there
how how it's hard
so I want to say say to these people and
stay strong and inshah so everything
will be good you've been you said
yourself you've been through some of
that in chur near yourself you saw War
you saw fighting you saw how has that
shaped your life how has that made you a
different man so I've been kid I wasn't
kid that time I didn't understand it's
world that time kids don't know what is
it War it's when you're kid it's become
first days hard makes you scared the
second day
like start to become a normal then you
think it all the world is like that you
know so kid is kid I was kid that time
and the most things I remember it was
after the war because I was like when I
was War I was like born then after the
war I was six years so it was hard
time and not so much food like you know
like everyone staying like family like
they do now all of us all Muslims stay
for the for Palestine now
so
yeah there a lot of hard things we went
through as
well they will be stronger people so
they will come back sh that country will
be free we pray for
that um I don't know if you saw but
there was some
back and forth between sha
Strickland and Bilal Muhammad Bal
Muhammad said something very simple like
pray for Palestine and then Shan
Strickland he called him a coward he
attacked him he started attacking Islam
he started attacking uh B Muhammad then
I went I said something to him myself on
Twitter I said why didn't you mention
ham because Hamza Chay he said something
similar he said pray for Palestine
something like that do you think Sha
Strickland is afraid of
[Applause]
[Music]
you I don't know man so shouldn't
be he has to be afraid so I can't for
him so inah we we fight with everyone
so we this the the fights in the cage is
not that big thing you
know if we can make some people happy
who is going through hard times and
Muslims all Muslims watching us and me
and Habib all the Muslim Fighters belal
and we know we know the all all of all
of the kids our kids they watching the
want to be like us and wants to be the
strong people inshallah we we try to be
in good picture for them and that stre
all these guys
they should be afraid of us we we fight
not just for us like they do we fight
for all Muslims that's
[Applause]
right now you've trained with Sean
Strickland in the past what do you make
of him I know it's not good Jim eeka to
talk about you know your sparring and
stuff but he he surprised us with his
performance against Israel adna his
striking was quite clean and crisp and
efficient he he knocked him down did you
find him difficult in the sparring no it
was the same fighter I knew I knew this
fight going to happen something is is
strange
but oh I was thinking like if Sean
strick not get down like in first round
I was thinking he going to win the fight
but I didn't say to anyone I was just
holding myself say it's happening so he
win the fight
he one of the like good Fighters not bad
so but for us is no problem inshah
inshah there no problematic he won't be
able to deal with your double leg
takeown 100% 100% no way well I mean
that's an interesting thing because Sean
Strickland has been saying some very
negative things I think everybody would
want to see him being demolished would
you
agree and I I
I I think that Shan Strickland is the
next match for you would you agree with
this do you think Dana White should make
that
fight 100% if he has the fight now who
is winning the fight he has good fighter
who was fighting
with the and if he wins against this guy
so for sure we're going to fight 100%
should be they promised for me that
fight
and so now we going wait who is winning
the fight and then take the belt you are
in Birmingham and this is the city of
Leon Edwards but having said
that the Muslim population Birmingham is
30% so I have a feeling that if you
fought Leon Edwards the people will be
on your side here in Birmingham what do
you
think yeah of course I feel like a home
here so alhamdulillah it's I'm so happy
so
lot of Muslims we going out every day
being here before as well with Dad and
we go out and seeing all our Muslim
Brothers they say Salam alayum it makes
me happy you know and around the world
wherever we go so when you see a Muslim
when he say Salam alaykum it makes you
happy because you see you fight your
brother you know
I'm tell us more about your relationship
with God like do you pray every day you
read Quran what kind of things do you do
in terms of
Islam alhamdulillah I'm praying every
day it makes I always when I was a kid
my brother said to me like that makes
different Muslim is not Muslim they when
you pray you pray five times a day since
since that time I pray every day
alhamdulillah
so and I'm I I don't I want to say I'm
the best Muslim and so so because I'm as
like like all of people of us like
happen like wrong things and try to make
it better so put the put the mic a bit
closer yes alhamdulillah we're trying to
uh Ramadan like fasting and five days
praying and uh listening like imams was
like translate I can't read the Quran I
listen the H translate the Quran to I
watching a lot of videos and a lot of
good imams listening to them go mus M as
well do you do you listen to any
particular
speakers yeah like K like as well oh you
listen to him yeah listen to him and
like we as
in they friend so listen to them as
well that's very good um do you think
that you know when you you're a Muslim
obviously you believe in God you believe
in there's a higher power you believe
God has the plan
all of these things we have as you know
taul the idea of tul Reliance on God
these are key Islamic principles do you
think that helps you when you're
fighting of course when you believe
Allah it makes you stronger than people
when you believe in nothing is you you
alone in the world when you have so much
power when in your heart when you
believes Allah it's always being Allah
being helping with everywhere when you
get to bad times alhamdulillah it makes
me out from everywhere I've been living
in the gym need have a food he have a
money alhamdulillah where I am today you
know so he makes me that people I am
today so I'm grateful for that so Allah
love being always with us so he makes
me much stronger people when I thinking
about him so no nothing can make us H
scar you know when I lack with that and
ask you a question you're 29 years old
now right yes um usually the fighter
finishes at let's say retires at 40 or
something like that I don't know maybe
in your division it's less or more I
don't know right but have you thought
about what you're going to do after
fighting yes of course so uh I start 23
I'm being first time in the gym so now
I'm 29 so you see all these fights
everything so as as my family my boy so
sh trying to do better things for the
kids and make them Choice the better way
a good way don't do the wrong things
uh teach them train be hard
and so I'm going to try to teach me as
well so Quran read Quran as well because
there's a comment saying people say that
the the Sportsman dies two deaths what
they mean by that is that a lot of
people when they retire because all they
know is their sport they become
depressed afterwards because they're not
doing that anymore so we've seen a lot
of sports people without mentioning
names do that and so thinking about what
you're going to do after fighting can
sometimes be a very important thing
because as I say fighting is going to
take about 10 years of your life after
that it's going to be maybe training but
maybe what you're doing here charity
yeah have you thought about that a
little bit more yeah of course always
been open for the the helping for the
people and doing charity all these
things media and we if we can help with
something with some way it just save the
world always be open for that this this
is when I start and I seen the videos it
was a lot of people around the world in
Africa out the food a lot of people
there as well so had hard time uh always
been my dream to help some people that
makes me happy when I help somebody it's
it's different different
happiness you do this and going to help
kids everything will be open for
everything brother
so how would you want to be remembered
so you said you said something very
powerful before I don't know if they
heard it but you said in a 100 years
we're not going to be here like in 100
years everyone is going to be dead and
that's a very powerful thing and that's
something the prophet Muhammad actually
told us as well so when we're all gone
how do you want to be
remembered so everyone as real human our
Prophet wasam mhamad he's never we we're
never going to forget him you know so he
is our prophet and we are human every if
we die everyone will forget us anyway so
sometimes some people will speak about
yeah he being fighter but I'm just a
Fighter fighting in the cage and uh
being people B and all these guys they
never were going to be forget they will
think about that so for me it's
important and be a good human be a good
Muslim
and when I go go there and get my
Paradise yeah I think what you're doing
is extremely important like a lot of the
the top fighters even in boxing muhamad
Ali being one of them right we don't
just remember them because of what they
did inside of the Ring we we remember
them because of what they did outside of
the ring and by coming here and showing
solidarity with the people of Palestine
this will never be forgotten will
it and this is the kind of thing which
inshallah will be part of your legacy in
D
and but I wanted to um put something to
you this is a charity event as you know
and uh just like you like to challenge
yourself I also like to challenge myself
and what I wanted to say is that look
we're trying to raise money for charity
today and uh it would be an honor and a
privilege if me and you did some
grappling in front of these
[Laughter]
[Applause]
people
I I um I I got my friend to get the mats
and he will bring it upstairs in the
middle of this place we'll do the first
one uh to do a takeown you they will win
is this okay with you brother we need to
Alive
brother but under one condition under
one
condition under one condition that when
the fundraising happens okay when the
fundraising happens that we need to get
at least
250,000 sterling pounds today okay we
will we will not do anything unless you
especially me I don't want to do
anything with this
man unless this money is paid for
charity and inshallah it will be
fantastic is that something okay of
course will thank you so much brother
okay with that I'll let you meet hamzat
and at the same time we'll bring the
mats up I'll get changed and we'll see
you in the middle of the
Ring take care my
friend